[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof hello walter good day
young man
are you well i'm fine ah that's good
interesting topics well the world is
moving in a direction
and nobody wants to admit that it's
yeah and that second word in the title
conspiracy
everything is being deemed a conspiracy
even the bible
everything is now a conspiracy let's
open with a word of prayer our heavenly
father
we need you again please we need your
enlightenment
that we can discuss these things
according to your will and we ask that
you bless us in jesus name
amen amen
there are some people who are
taking note that there are certain
changes in the world
which are strange to say the least yeah
yeah
now we don't want to get into a heavy
discussion
on any of these issues but we do
want to set the record straight as to
what we believe about this book
correct and i'm not going to be
apologetic about the fact that i believe
what this book says
i didn't always believe what the book
said
but having tested it and
come to the conclusion that it is
definitely not a man-made
document because that is impossible
there are too many nuances
yes and if you take the period that was
written
it's just impossible that the flow
that's in there that it could be
and the chiasms and the parallelisms
and the merisms and you name it
and the the consistency of the message
throughout it's just amazing
and every time you read it you're
reading a new book
and i've read many books in my life
and some i've read more than once
because particularly in your academic
career you have to refresh yourself
but when you read this book over and
over again
you're reading a new book every single
time true
and there was a court case once where
they took a man's bible to see what his
thinking patterns were
and they looked at all the places that
he'd underlined
to see what his thinking patterns were
and i thought about that for a while you
know every time you read this book
you find something else to underline so
if they wait long enough everything's
underlined
that's true that's true yes
so let's jump right into it and uh we
don't want to
be tedious but let's see where we can go
sky news had an interesting
little discussion the other day about
uh what people consider conspiracies
these days
and the the news commentator
who was quite irate about these things
and he said many things
which we would actually also say right
that's correct now we don't do not want
to
play the whole thing we'll put the link
in there
and people can watch it for themselves
but just the introduction is
interesting so let us see where we are
going
well i've frequently spoken about the
great reset this is the plan by the
world economic forum
to encourage governments to use all the
levers they use during
lockdown enforced business closures
23-hour lockdowns
restricting how far you can go from your
home and ridiculously aggressive
policing tactics
in order to tackle climate change
so martin he has quite a long discussion
about everything that
people claim to be conspiracy theories
and he's
stating how can it be a conspiracy if
you're
quoting these people directly right
that's a question we also ask
that's a question we also ask and you
know we get it from
from all sides from the theological
side from the secular side just read the
news
then you wouldn't have to complain about
all of these things
and you wouldn't have to flag us as
conspiracy theorists the whole time
yes so let's uh leave it at that not
play anything more but
it's quite fun watching what the man has
to say
so he was also accused of being a
conspiracy theorist
for quoting the news and they even
linked him to q anon as well so
well he's in good company let's have a
look at what's happening in the world
because
there is a distinct denial
that we are heading in a particular
direction in this world
and the fact that that
direction is clearly portrayed
in the bible seems to be irritating some
forces out
there right yes and
the closer that connection becomes the
more irritated
some people are becoming and the louder
they will scream
and say that this is an apocalypse
conspiracy
well let's have a look at a few news
items just to get us into the mood
the vatican of course is making a big
issue of the fact that the pope is
finally going to
iraq yes for the first time ever
so iraqi cardinal louis sacco
patriarch of babylon of the chaldeans
told vatican radio stefano
i don't think i'll pronounce that one
that as the entire population prepares
to welcome pope francis
something has already changed in the
nation
that's interesting yeah just the mere
fact
that he visits a place changes a nation
some of the photos and so on i saw that
they've got posters up
and they're really they're getting yet
for this
christians and muslims alike said
cardinal sacco
are busy preparing posters of greetings
and all media outlets are saying welcome
pope francis we are
happy to welcome you this
is what we've been talking about that
the whole world
even those that are supposedly so
anti-christianity
are wandering after the beast
and it's interesting to me i listened to
the clip of what pope francis himself
had to say
and he was saying this is absolutely
necessary for the common good
now the bible talks about come out and
be separate
you're supposed to preach a gospel of
salvation to the entire world
but this common good seems to negate
that
right we have to all work together
in a synchronistic system
uh accepting that everyone is at exactly
the same level
which absolutely negates the
proclamation of the gospel
so it's interesting that these moves are
afoot and that the pope is carrying on
with his mission
to me it was also interesting that he
was speaking about
spiritual fraternity yes
spiritual fraternity uh
what does that mean it means that we're
all brothers and sisters on the same
level right
yes uh our last hope
is another interesting point our last
hope
he underscored how one of the focuses of
the journey
will be on fraternity a spiritual
fraternity
which he said will be especially
highlighted when
the holy father travels to ur the
birthplace of
abraham also in the forefront cardinal
sacco continued
is the inter-religious aspect of the
journey
that foresees amongst others a meeting
with the ayatollah it will have
a big impact for christians
and muslims so they're linking
as they have done for many years now
back
to abraham as the father of the
monotheistic
religions in the world yes you remember
in one of our first what's up profs we
showed
this link where the they have a
church and a synagogue and a
mosque that's going to be built in saudi
arabia and this is
the same thing yes yeah yes it's like
chrislam except of course they have to
expand that word to include
the jewish religion as well
all right that was just to keep us up to
date with where we're going in the world
and the interesting fact is
that people say this is the last hope
for what for peace right correct and the
bible says when they say
peace and safety then that will signal
that the end has come now here's another
video that we want to show where
there is an attempt to drag
the way in which the trump supporters
think and how they act into this
conspiracy
theory idea it seems to me
that there is a very concerted effort
to try and marginalize any
form of thinking that
to the collective world is
a danger any form of separatism
any form of going back to the old ways
other than this great reset this
new mode of thinking this re-education
has to be marginalized and the best way
to do this
is through ridicule yep isn't that
interesting
if you go to the bible what was peter's
down for
he was ready to go to war yes he was
ready to pick up the sword
he was ready to slash heads but he only
got an ear
but his downfall was ridicule
that is the bane of
any fringe society and eventually people
will capitulate
to ridicule john that
well under the ridicule that's why he
could stand yes when he went into the
room
but peter peter peterfell
what were your thoughts on the violent
insurrection incited by trump at the
capitol oh my god that's all such a lie
that was all the left we have all the
proof there's tons of proof
january 6 was a plan that was
pre-planned
by the democrats i knew that it was
pre-organized by antifa
what did you think of what happened on
the 6th on the 6th
6th of january the violent insurrection
what did you think of that
that's what you guys call it the
insurrection what would you call it well
i call it a movement by the communists
to make it look like trumpers did it
that's what i call it so many trump
supporters arrested at us well that's
what you guys say i don't believe that
you prove it to me
i mean there's all the indictments i
mean whatever you guys say i don't
believe any of it
right to tell you the truth these trump
supporters are in denial about what
happened on january 6
and some believe in q anon
what's going to happen at some point is
there'll be arrests
and that'll include a lot of the line
media and then they'll be military
that's what happens they keep saying
that for years and it's not it hasn't
been years it hasn't
been since 2017. it's been years now
we're taking
this is a 6 000 year old death cult you
can't take it down that quick
i understand you're very passionate
trump supporter right
but you you surely
you surely can admit that the people who
stormed the capital
or trump's supporters no i definitely
cannot in fact you're talking to the
right person
because i can send you tons of footage
that shows that that was all
the left dressed up the answer for the
blm dressed up as trump's
it is my hope that president trump comes
back
as the 19th president of the united
states
under the 1776
and that he is inaugurated on march 4th
that is my hope for our future
some have bought into a new conspiracy
theory that trump
will return as the 19th president
on march 4th why well they have
misinterpreted
an 1871 law and believe
ulysses s grant who was inaugurated on
march 4
1869 was america's last
legitimate president it may all sound
bizarre but
online discussion about march 4 has been
a contributing factor in the decision to
keep the national guard in washington dc
are you going to feel foolish on march
5th when biden's still president
[Music]
then trump has a different plan than
play
everybody keeps saying trump has a plan
he has a plan when he lost the election
they said he has a plan he's definitely
trying to
lose the election sir trump did not lose
the election
and that's where we we differ right and
that's where
i believe the information
that mike lindell has put out the pillow
guy
of all of the abuse
corruption stealing you trust a man you
trust a man more who sells pillows than
the republican officials
in georgia oh absolutely but do you
realize that sounds
let me just tell you that the people in
georgia
are sick and while most of the world
looks on
in horror at a deadly military coup in
myanmar
that's exactly what these trump
supporters hope to see happen here
in the united states of america this
whole thing with biden
is just he's like a puppet president uh
the military is in charge it's going to
be like myanmar what's happening in
myanmar the military is doing their own
investigation and at the right time
they're going to be restoring the
republic with trump as president
in different countries the government
took over and they're redoing the
election
would you like to see it happen i would
like to see it really yes you know why
because the election was stolen from us
i never would have believed cnn would
have given me a chance to speak the
truth no
what a miracle praise god i mean but
we're going to say in our news report
that q anon is a conspiracy theory you
don't believe q anon is a conspiracy
theory
oh i know it isn't i know it isn't i'm
not much for believing i have to know
well martin what do you think cnn has in
mind
by making a program like this to
discredit them to discredit them
now please don't misunderstand
we're not giving them any credit here
either
this is not the issue this is a game
yes and they have a lot of experience in
playing this game if you continue with
the narrative over and over and over
again
eventually people will be
channeled into a direction of thinking
now the fourth of march has come
and has gone so as this lady there said
well then there must be another plan
right
yes and these plans will just continue
a sense both sides
are at loggerheads about something that
they
do not fully comprehend what is the
real agenda behind this
type of hype that they are creating
to discredit a line of thinking
because what did they do with the
millerite
movement exactly the same thing they put
it to discredit that whole thing they
linked it to q and on and now they just
keep continuing to discredit all of this
and as that lady said
you can't dismantle a 6 000 year
issue just like that so
what is interesting to me martin is that
there are elements of truth
yes and this is what makes it
so interesting the element of truth is
there is a decline
in morality in the world nobody can deny
that
there is a movement towards
creating some form of
new program out of chaos
that's been a masonic plan all along
if you have enough chaos you have an
opportunity
to create a new order of things a great
reset correct totally new mindset
and this new mindset will bring about
that beautiful word fraternity yes
common good and then finally all of
these
fringes will have been removed from
society
and we can get on with the business
but that's exactly where the danger lies
because if you allow for all the
injustices that are taking place
in the world if you allow for the
degradation
of society in the way in which it is
going
you are at the same time on a collision
course
on a collision course with this book
because then you're gonna try and
discredit
what that book says exactly so
we're not taking sides in this issue
we're just observing
the game play exactly this is what's
going on
and don't get caught up with it
don't hook yourself to something that is
actually
relevant so you cannot
swallow the whole system
because there are a few points within
the system that are relevant
yes you have to ask yourself the
question
where is this leading to
so while we were talking about the
points of
morality there's no denying
that the world has become a very strange
place right
correct in the old days when a child was
born
you immediately knew what gender it
it was it wasn't it wasn't rocket
science
to determine the gender correct
and once you had determined the gender
which took a few seconds
then you could decide whether the room
was going to be pink or blue
that's the way it was and what kind of
toys there would be in the room would it
be prams and dolls and
and things like that or would it be
cranes and cars
and things like that yeah but that's all
changed right
so here is a new law california law
would find department stores one
thousand
dollars for separating toys by gender
stores would not have to change their
products that but the products
could not be displayed based on how they
have
traditionally been marketed for either
girls or boys
hasbro the company that made the potato
shaped plastic toy
for nearly 70 years announced this week
it is giving the mr potato head a
gender neutral name
he's just going to be potato head mr is
going to be gone
the change will appear on boxes this
year
now no offense martin but the potato
looks very masculine it's totally bald
for one
[Laughter]
but of course uh you can change that you
can put a little wig on the back
i wonder there was a movie called toy
story
yeah and then there was a mr potato head
but there was also a mrs potato head so
they probably want to change her name
then as well yes you can't remove the
mister without removing the mr
misses that would be discrimination
wouldn't it
great and and if you think how far this
goes
that you now have a choice as to which
washroom you want to use
and uh i mean these things are
ridiculous
joe biden made it quite plain
that you should be able to decide which
washroom you want to go in in the old
days you would
get clobbered right yeah but that's all
changed
so is there a shift in morality
though definitely where do we get the
standard for morality
the standard of morality is actually
recorded in this book
and this is going against what that book
says but there are people that say this
is a patriarchal system
yeah right so do you want to go back to
an old-fashioned
patriarchal system now
did women not have a prominent role in
this bible weren't there prophet tesses
yes all right yeah wasn't deborah a
judge for israel so he was a
leader correct but that doesn't change
the fact
that god has put a order
in place it was not an order of
subjection
no because eve came out of adam's
side she didn't come from underfoot
she came from adam's side and the two
shall be one so
you know the bible is actually very
balanced but
obviously not balanced enough for some
people
here's an interesting article now we're
not taking
a stand here on uh
how we think about this morality we're
just
stating what is happening in the world
here's an interesting article and it has
a very interesting
title gay polyamorous thrall
with children say it's no big deal that
their kids have
three dads in a new book three dads and
a baby
said to be released next week one of the
fathers dr
ian jenkins details the reproductive
journey
he and his partners embarked upon in
order to become
father to their daughter piper who is
now three years old
the thrapple now also have a
one-year-old son
named parker piper who is now in
preschool
is alleged to have proudly told the
classmate you have two parents
i have three parents we're not
discussing the morality of this
issue but surely times have changed
definitely this would not have been even
remotely possible
a decade ago or two decades ago at most
so things are changing all right so now
we've seen
that there is this this plan to put
people
into conspiratorial categories
to streamline a way of thinking forward
to incorporate new ways of
thinking about morality and then there
are ways
in which these things can be enforced
yes how your movements can be enforced
and the the covet crisis was very useful
for this so here's an article
about europe in breitbart everyone
agreed
on vaccine passports says merkel
at a eu summit now it's not only the
the european union israel has introduced
it
there's talk in many of the countries in
africa to introduce it
this passport is on the agenda
michael said that such a system could be
implemented
as soon as the summer so there's a great
rush
to get the system in place european
commission president russell von leon
praised israel's implementation of the
green
passes a system in which the government
tracks
and documents an individual's
vaccination history
in order to facilitate travel or to
attend synagogues theaters
concerts or to go to the gym
now in our own country there was a
promise that it wouldn't happen
yeah he wouldn't be forced you wouldn't
be forced
but there are ways and means of doing
this
without the government actually
enforcing it as
in the case of israel the counter for
enforcement is restriction correct
education secretary gavin williamson
backed up the plan to carry passports to
go to restaurants cinemas
theaters telling lbc radio on wednesday
i think i would probably do pretty much
sort of
anything to be able to enjoy all those
lovely things
so here is a form of coercion
and it's interesting to me there are so
many media reports we're not going to
talk about them
about the efficacy
of all of these rules and regulations
that have been
implemented and how the negative
side of them the downside is being
downplayed yes and the upside is
being made prominent it's actually
interesting if you talk against any of
these things
you're silenced absolutely you're not
allowed to talk about things and there
are
statistics coming out which we will not
discuss at the moment
which show the negative effects and
even death rates but
we won't go there because we want to
stay
on our platforms for a while
but people should have a look and see
what is happening in the world
and is this really something that is
necessary
there's even talk of of major court
cases
against governments and all of these
things
now the vatican is always in the mix
always always in the mix and this is the
point we're trying to get across right
always in the mix and the bible tells us
yes he's going to be in the mix the
whole time
now is that a conspiracy unless you see
the whole bible as a conspiracy
and you can't say it it's just the fact
it's like that first little video clip
that man just put it as it was right
no jab no job vatican gets tough with
covert
anti-vaxxers the vatican has told
employees
that they may risk losing their jobs if
they refuse to get a covet 19
vaccination without legitimate health
reasons
a decree by cardinal giuseppe bertello
effectively the governor of vatican city
said getting a vaccine was the
responsible choice
because of the risk of harming other
people
i read an interesting article about
the collective the other day
and it talked about the collective being
non-existent if it weren't for the
individual
yeah it's true so you know where
is the basis is it the individual or is
it the collective
of course with the vatican it's the
collective and not the individual
but with the bible it's the individual
exactly
because there has to be an individual
choice
so has the collective the right to force
the individual
that is a very good question
especially when conscience is involved
and you know history has proved that the
majority is always right right
uh no no oh unfortunately
okay so don't quote me on that
the vatican has made a covet 19
vaccination obligatory
for journalists accompanying pope
francis on his trip to iraq
next month
interesting that even the vaccine
companies themselves
say that the vaccination doesn't
guarantee
that you will not be able to transmit
the virus but be that as it may
the interesting part here is the vatican
leads by
example yes and the nations
are singing the same tune they're all on
middle c
when it comes to this issue
now of course they have to ensure that
people conform to these
new directives right
so enter the spy networks
a recent report estimates about a
billion security cameras rolling
worldwide
18 of them here in the united states the
us
is second only to china when it comes to
keeping eyes on its citizens
make no mistake big brother is watching
according to safety.com
the average american is caught on camera
238 times
each week wow
here's how those 238 camera views rack
up
cameras capture you at home or in your
neighborhood
14 times a week 160 times behind the
wheel
while you're working candid cameras
catch you 40
times maybe more if you're in retail
travel
or high security industries and 24 times
a week while shopping
or running errands right now we have
about 15
cameras for every 100 people in america
about 50 million cameras and that's more
per capita than any other country in the
world even china i mean the basic
concern is that we're going to
lose our privacy and we're going to
become a country that's different from
what we've always been
that from the moment you step out of
your front door until you return home at
night
every moment of your life in public will
be recorded
potentially scrutinized washed he says
it's often
artificial intelligence keeping track
not humans
computers that analyze your daily
routines and understand what you're
doing what you're carrying what you're
wearing who you are what your attributes
are
and filing that away somewhere you don't
expect privacy on the street corner
so if a camera captures what you're
doing in the street corner
i don't think that's an intrusion on
privacy ucla law professor
eugene volok believes the positives
outweigh the negatives
both experts agree the biggest concern
is the potential for government
tracking its citizens under the guise of
crime prevention
we're seeing some cities like chicago
putting
police cameras all over the city and
networking them together they're also
tying in
private cameras in some cases the ring
cameras
are being networked together by amazon
which takes all the camera feeds and
puts them in the cloud
potentially making them available to the
authorities part of the solution experts
say is
private citizens asking themselves
several questions before installing
cameras on personal property
do you trust the manufacturer who may
store images
on their own servers do you trust the
internet
because any cameras tied to the web are
susceptible to being hacked
and do you trust the government that in
many cases can use a warrant
to access what your camera captures
now the point of all of this martin is
not to reiterate a well-known story
over and over but just to say that the
bible says
that rich or poor it doesn't matter
you will not be able to partake in
certain activities
buying and selling in particular
mentioned in the bible
in other words you won't be able to go
to the theater you won't be able to go
to the shop you won't be able to do that
if you do not conform to
the system do they have the mechanism in
place
yes to enforce it yes and
maybe it's also important to reiterate
that eventually what we've been talking
about
the sunday the sunday legislation and
all of this that will be coming in
will not be something new it's not going
to be this is
it's just going to be a next step
correct this is already being
implemented on these levels so when that
happens
it's just the next step so people won't
be so alerted
to see oh now it's here correct
so the question is do we see this trend
the decline in morality the surveillance
systems
the new way of thinking the channeling
into a system of fraternity
common good requiring certain
measures to be taken to save the planet
from
climate change calamities sunday
legislation being very much
part of the issue do we see this trend
yes or no definitely yes
now how many times have we been
asked what's your big deal with the
sunday issue
there you go again with the sunday issue
this is not important to many people
what difference does it make what day
you keep
why do you keep hammering the sunday
issue
perhaps we should just spend the moment
just to clarify this issue yes
is it a question of a day or does it
have a
much deeper significance now
sunday legislation has been part of
humanity
for a very very long time yes and we
will be seeing just now
that they are celebrating or that they
celebrated the 1700 years
of sunday legislation it's been there
for a long time but the bible
clearly indicates that in the end there
will be a
universal decree implementing
the mark of the beast
now this question of a mark is a very
important thing and when rome declares
out of its own volition that sunday
is the mark of her authority
and that the change of the day
from the saturday to the sunday is proof
of the fact that they have this
authority
then that word authority is the
principle word
not the day no when the authority
is the proof that they can change the
day then what is of more importance the
day or the authority the authority
the authority okay
so let's go back in history
and just talk about this for a while
if you go to genesis chapter 2 we've
done this so many times
but i will just read quickly from
genesis chapter 2 here
where it says thus the heavens and the
earth were
finished that's a very important word
done deal and all the host of them
and on the seventh day god ended his
work which he had
made and he rested on the seventh day
from
all his work which he had made and god
blessed the seventh day and sanctified
it
because that in it he had rested from
all his work which god created
and made right there in genesis
so this applies to how much of humanity
all of it all of it right because there
was only an adam and eve
yes and by one blood god has created all
the nations
so this sabbath was for whom
for men for man it was for everyone
it was for everyone and it is the symbol
of his creation if you go to exodus
chapter 20 and you look at the
ten commandments two of the commandments
are exceedingly long they're on the
first
tablet there it says
quite clearly that you may not make for
yourself
an image idolatry is explained in great
detail
that commandment has been removed
now we had a question the other day
which we haven't answered yet
where some people say but they've looked
in the catholic bible and it isn't
changed
yes no they they didn't change it in the
bible the bible no
but they changed it in their catechism
yes
and where's their authority correct
then the categories lies in the
catechism because
that is their creed yes and you have to
abide by the creed
and they have a whole council the
congregation for doctrine and faith
which enforces the decrees of the
catechism the catechism
stands above scripture alone
so the second commandment was removed
and the fourth commandment
which is also a long
commandment explaining
what the sabbath is all about and that
you must cease from your work in other
words you are not
to work for your relationship with god
you're supposed to
enjoy your relationship with god and
remind yourself where you come from
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shall you labor and do all your
work
but the seventh day is the sabbath
and then it tells you what you're not
supposed to do and then it says quite
clearly for in
six days referring back to genesis
god made the heavens
the earth the sea the springs of water
in other words
everything and he rested on the seventh
day
and he declared it holy and set it aside
right
so there you have the seal of god you
have the seal of his authority he's the
creator god
he's the one who made
therefore he has the right to say which
day has been set aside
and that is his seal of authority now
what does
rome say is the seal of her authority
changing that day
okay so we're not talking about the day
the day is incidental yes but we're
talking about the authority
exactly so when you touch the authority
of god
and you negate the authority of god
then you are attacking the authority
of your creator if you go to deuteronomy
chapter 5
where the law is again written with the
finger of god
on new tablets because moses broke the
first one
which was symbolic of a broken law yes
because they had broken the law right
and he threw down the tablets and they
broke he didn't sin
no it was symbolic of the breaking of
the law
and the wording on the new tablets is
slightly different
it says remember that you were slaves in
egypt and the lord took you out of there
with the mighty hand
therefore you must keep the sabbath so
the sabbath has
become not only a sign of creation
it has become a sign of redemption yes
how many redeemers are there only one
isn't there supposed to be a fraternity
and everybody has the same way to heaven
or is the bible quite clear that there's
only one name
yes under heaven on earth whereby you
can be saved
and didn't that one that it refers to
say that he is lord of the sabbath
correct
so who has the authority
to proclaim the day
set aside to rest in the completed works
of god
who has that authority jesus yes
who claims that authority on earth the
roman catholic church
the roman catholic church so this is
a clash of authority yes if you have
fraternity
then that verse that by only the name of
jesus you can be saved this god has to
get out
as they cannot move what did that french
minister have to say about the law of
god
it must be subject to the law of the
muslims
isn't that exactly the same thing who
are you attacking
god the authority of god now
which law in the ten commandments
gives validity and force to the
entire ten commandments the fourth
commandment
only the fourth commandment only because
any other
leader god anything could write the
other nine
commandments right so the authority for
the entire law of god
rests in the fourth commandment the one
who is speaking
is the creator yes i made
what did he make heaven and earth and
everything
in it therefore
i told you i commanded you i reminded
you
to keep the fourth commandment now
when humanity has attacked
the commandment in the past there's been
much turmoil and a lot of blood
if you take the valdanzas how many of
them died
the albiganses the celts you name it
the church of the east the ethiopian
church how much
blood flowed over the sabbath sunday
issue
but it was always just a portion of the
world
yes right now martin
when the whole world decides
to negate god's command and get rid of
it
then the whole world will stand as
one denying god
his authority correct and giving
that authority to someone else
who claims to have changed the day of
worship
to prove his authority it's a clash of
authorities
so is it a big deal definitely
and why is it that it's being kept for
the very
last moment why isn't this thing being
done
before well it has been done there have
been laws in europe
there have been laws in the united
states very strict sunday laws yes
there were laws in our own country when
i was a young
person living in this country they were
very strong i remember
even there when i was uh young
the my wife's grandmother who would
forbid
needlework on that day because she said
that needle will stab god in the eye
you're not allowed to do anything on a
sunday
and they're bringing this issue back
so now because it's happening on a
universal scale
universally the world is saying
we do not accept the authority
of god it is the final step
in a great apostasy
there are so many laws coming down the
pike
where people are saying what is going on
with the world that video
yeah about the morality and the and the
trump followers
they're saying what's happening to the
world correct
why is god not yet intervened
because there has not been a universal
setting aside of his authority
correct how would you do that if you in
one fell swoop
wanted to attack god's authority
and remove it from society
what law would you make that you don't
keep the law
the day or that acknowledges him
as the true god and creator so you would
make a sunday law
yes that's the last step that's the last
step
and when you've done that yeah because
if you if you you say
okay you want to negate the no don't
steal law
but that's the law of the country it's
no big deal yeah
but you make a sunday law you're
negating
the authority of god and that is why it
is a big deal
and that is why i for one
had to change my view not only from an
atheist to a believer
but also to acknowledge where i come
from and who saved me
and the only way i can do that
is by keeping the law as it is written
by god
and not changed by man yes and
for those that have a problem with
us speaking on the issue of the sunday
you'll have to buckle up because it's
not going to end here it's not going to
end it's going to come again and again
it's like talking about the papacy
we're not going to stop talking about it
because it's the lead horse
finished that is what we are supposed to
be looking at
because people are wondering after this
exactly
here's an article from newsday about
what's happening in trinidad
and tobago now you might say well that's
the corner of the world
but if this is an issue that is
happening universally then it becomes a
different story right
but let's look here let's keep sunday
sacred sunday is the soul of the nation
it is more than just a fanatical
religious
preoccupation there is a reason why the
day
was woven into the fabric of our society
we have to save sunday
historically the practice of reserving a
day for rest was the best thing for a
fledgling nation
it was biblical in intent and economical
in its effect it offered intangible
rewards
such as resting from the labors of life
and connecting with the divine
in pastimes the law protected sunday
limiting labor and the opening of bars
and business
but we have since flipped in the
importance of the day
the old ordinances have been left in the
dusty corners of the library of laws
the common law as an astute reflection
of the soul and intent of men
in their moral duties has revealed where
we
are as a nation is that they're not
prudent
just and fair that we should preserve
the sanctity of the day called
sunday let us be
the remnant that holds this day to be
sacrosanct to our society
let us keep the sacredness of sunday in
its rightful place
as central to the resolution of problems
in our nation
we have to preserve the order of things
or the disorder will destroy us
let's save sunday for our nation's sake
that's a very interesting speech yes so
the disorder will destroy us we need
a new order we need order
out of this chaos and there's also
let us be the remnant that hold this day
to sacrifice
to our society correct the bible also
refers to a remnant that will be
holding the full ten commandments
just before the end correct so let's
listen to the speech by the prime
minister of barbados and listen
carefully because it affects the entire
world
people are making tremendous sacrifices
for the sake of the national good
and as i've thanked so many others
tonight i want to thank the majority of
you barbadians
who have literally risen to the call and
have stayed put
and i've ensured that in many instances
you have also become part and parcel of
our national compliance
effort ensuring that persons who you
know
are doing the wrong thing that you are
telling us and you're telling them to
at the same time my friends i've also
said to them
and responded to the minister of health
was asked that we do not have
commercial activity in supermarkets
hardware stores
or any stores on sundays for now and
therefore when these things
open back up on the 1st of march it will
be business
from monday to saturday but there will
be no
commerce in the supermarkets on sunday
we feel that the workers there and the
persons who are monitoring
and i ask beijins to think about the
people who have to work as monitors
who have to work in enforcement who have
to work in the supermarkets they're
under pressure too
and let them have sunday as the day of
rest while we fight this out
and let us give sunday as a time to be
able to move forward
it's interesting that you even mentioned
the surveillance there
and tell us about it when you see people
not conforming and tell them about it so
the nation must become involved they
must be on the same wavelength
and they must police each other yes and
sunday must become
a day of rest for the collective common
good
correct all right so
let's jump from barbados to
the european continent and this is a law
in spain since when do you rest on
sundays
the sunday rest act has been enforced
for more than 100 years tomorrow
the march the 4th is the anniversary of
a law
that changed the labor paradigm in spain
this is the sunday rest law which
introduced the prohibition of working on
sundays
regardless of economic activity
something unthinkable previously
but since when has this law been
enforced
the sunday rest act was introduced in
however the law was not approved by any
party
but this took place on december the 12th
that day congress approved the law that
prohibits working on sunday but it was
promulgated on march 3
published on the official state gazette
on march the 4th of the same month and
entered into force on sunday september
11 of the year
in question now many of these laws
martin have been on the books
the blue laws in the united states and
in many countries
they are there they are slumbering
waiting to be enacted
question is there a move to activate
them
yes why would these articles be
appearing
in the newspapers all over the world and
one of the
driving forces is climate change
to awaken these laws again now we're
jumping to the united states right
advancing from oklahoma senate panel
a bill by senator adam pugh would allow
car dealerships to sell vehicles on
sunday
the bill would allow dealerships to sell
on sundays
in reacting to that idea canda requires
me to confess some personal bias
in a formal life i once posted a church
and i still wear the clerical collar
figuratively speaking canda further
requires us all to note
that the roots of sunday laws aka blue
laws
go back to a time when the federal
constitutional prohibition of religious
establishment
applied only to the federal government
that some states passed sunday or blue
laws for the avowed purpose of
encouraging worship was in most quarters
not even viewed as a problem
all of that said there is ample
secular justification for legally
setting aside a day of rest
secular justification one of my
grandfathers
was a car salesman and even though he
was not a church-going man he was
thankful for a day
when he could be with his family now
this argument has been
the argument of the papacy all along we
need a
family day we need a rest day we'll see
but wasn't that also the same
initiate idea of constantine
exactly that's exactly what he did
so here the alliance for the free sunday
3rd of march 2021 free sunday celebrates
anniversary 1700 years ago
on the 3rd of march 302
a.d and they tell you about constantine
that promulgated the law
and that they would like to retain
that law so this is a massive movement
yeah
all over the world yes and now this one
this alliance for sunday had their
big celebration on the third correct
now you know people always say what
about the muslim world
they keep friday no they don't they have
a short period of worship on a friday
but their stores are open on a friday
when is the international day of rest
for the banking system
so this is universal it's already
entrenched in every single
nation in the world it's just a
small step with the right initiative
to finally bring about a universal
decree
that will undermine the authority
of god and persecution will be part of
the final one absolutely and
surveillance by your brothers and
sisters
so when they recently had these
celebrations in europe
commemorating the 1700 years
this is what was said by a spokesperson
for the alliance
hi my name is alex and i'm policy
advisor at
commissi which is the commission of the
bishops conference of the european union
with the covid19 pandemic many people
are suffering from poverty
and loneliness this is why we need
fraternity more than ever
we need to care for each other for we
are all members of one human family
this is why at comace we are committed
to promote sunday
as a common weekly day of rest in the
european union
a day that gives time for family and
spiritual life
a day to experience social friendship
and fraternity
now the wording all the buzzwords are
there
fraternity common good all of these
issues now this organization
is called come say and it just
echoes basically what the vatican is
saying correct
so again you always have
the lead figure pushing the agenda
in the background well here's another
video
this one is in german so perhaps we can
go step by step and stop it occasionally
and
see what it says and you can explain to
us what's being said
1700 years of a
free sunday now
bear with us as we look at a few points
here
[Music]
at last a free sunday
where we can sit as a family around the
breakfast table
and take time to enjoy it
backtracks
when the amazons
[Music]
martin what they're saying is that she
works all day
in that store comes home late at night
the kids are in bed already she has no
time for the family
and the husband is a is a hairdresser
and he spends 10 hours standing
a day but on sundays he can put up his
feet
and be with the family so these are the
arguments they are using for a free
sunday so let's continue to watch
on techniques
so now he just said that if there were
no sunday we would have to invent one
because you know humanity needs it so
the little girl asks
where does this come from and now he's
going to give a history
and let's see what he says the history
is
biblica
targaryen so it all began
with the creation and you see the seven
days going by and on the seventh day
god rested yes but then of course
things have to change because we have to
move from the seventh day to the first
day of the week so let's see how they
justify it
fire in the uden brightside
from freitag
so the jews have kept the sabbath
according to the bible
for three thousand years and they kept
the seventh day which is the saturday
as the sabbath now let's see how it
progresses
the kaiser constantine so
under the christian dispensation the day
developed
into sunday but there was no law
governing it so that law came
under the leadership of the emperor
constantine underwritten
for thousands of constantine
sounds
[Music]
so constantine made a decree
that there must be rest on the
venerable day of the sun
they quite openly admit that it was a
day
on which the heathen venerated the sun
it's sun worship for this middle altas
the emperor charles in the middle ages
was the first then to expand this issue
and to make very clear what was
permissible
and what was not permissible so
on sundays it was not permitted to
sheer sheep it was not permissible to
make clothing
or to do your washing or to do any
sowing
and for men you weren't allowed to build
houses you weren't allowed to
fell trees you weren't allowed to plow
and you weren't allowed to
mow your fields so there were very
strict rules which
were different from what constantine
actually did
because he permitted farmers to continue
their work
but here the laws became stricter
in the neutral side the franciscan
revolutionary warning
storm
many accolades
in their free industrialized
proletariats
industries
then in germany during the industrial
revolution
the machinery had to keep working and so
work became a common feature on sunday
but at least they forbade the working
for children
and it is
then in 1919 finally
sunday came back onto the books and
article 139
it became a recognized
day of rest
and this law applies to this day so it's
on the books
it's on the books
so there are many reasons amongst them
human rights why you should keep the law
and the only work that is permitted is
work
that is necessary for the common good so
all of these laws are already there yeah
abandoned
and with this the issue is as clear as
the sun
sunday belongs to us and not to industry
why does mommy have to work sometimes on
sunday
there are too many exceptions that are
permissible
so they're saying that must change
escaped about the alliance for the
foreign
that is why we have this organization
which includes trade unions
the sporting bodies of the world that
are fighting for
the sunday results
like that
we should all do something to ensure
that sunday
remains a rest day wonderful
so let's start immediately so we have a
relaxing scene coming up
and we will see what is permissible
on a sunday now
that video was obviously also geared at
the youth right martin
because they had these little clay
figures and the whole family was there
the family but the alliance for the free
sunday
celebrating the 1700 year commemoration
of
the law of constantine wanted to make
sure that people
understand what the sunday is about
so they also have a video on what is
permissible
to make it attractive right you have to
change the mindset
of the people so let's look at that
[Music]
so
what i find interesting in that one is
there's no religion mentioned there it's
a small part
tiny little part if you compare
the biblical sabbath to the sunday that
they want
it's almost as if you can
on this sunday it's a very secular day
yes sports
games did you see how excited they were
in front of the television because of
some sporting event obviously
now the sport we've dealt with it before
and i know this is a very
mute point with many people but actual
fact
that is part of the second commandment
thou shalt not make for yourself an
idol it became can become
such an idol that it consumes your
entire life
and uh i remember in my own life how
fanatical i was about sport
that i would destroy the television if
you if my team lost
i mean i i think back on that it was on
the same page were you on the same page
and now it's become it's irrelevant
you know it's a game who cares who wins
because next year the other team's going
to win anyway
right maybe you're lucky and they win
two years in a row but
yeah well it's part of
idolatry so the sunday is not the same
as the sabbath
exactly you can't compare what you've
just seen in that video for what to do
the sabbath is set aside for a delight
in god correct and you can do many of
these things
you can go for walks in nature
you can rest on the sabbath but it's
time to spend with god and
his work and his work in nature and he's
working the word
and contemplating and being with
like-minded people who
love to serve god instead of fitting god
in to that day that day is about god
very well put martin very well put
but let's bring it back to the religious
side because behind this entire movement
sets the one who claims to be
the vicar of christ
here is the vatican news from 4 march eu
bishops call for nations to protect
work free sunday that word over there
nations is that plural yes
does it only include one or two
countries or
this is a universal request
the bishop of the european union and the
european sunday alliance so they're
working together right
yes the one the sunday alliance is
making it attractive even to the secular
world
and now you have big brother standing
behind it and saying
there's another reason to protect
synchronized free time which most
nations traditionally
observe on sunday
according to the network which includes
more than 100
national sunday alliances trade unions
employers organizations civil society
association
churches religious communities and the
european union
a full day of rest per week is
indispensable to recover
that might be so martin but god set
aside a very specific day
and as they quite openly say here
they keep it by tradition yes in vain
they worship me
teaching for doctrine the commandments
of men you have set aside god's law by
your
traditions indeed they say a common day
of
rest truly increases well-being and
brings a positive effect
on health only during a common day of
rest
is it possible to pursue volunteer work
civic engagement joint social sports or
faith related activities
family time more generally to spend
time together the statement explains
so they're reiterating what the alliance
has said
in particular the european network calls
on the european commission
to align its upcoming proposal for a
directive
on a right to disconnect with article 2
of the council of european social
charter which already requires
a weekly rest period which shall
as far as possible coincide with the day
recognized by
tradition or custom
in the country or region concerned as a
day of rest
martin the devil has been planning this
for a very very long time
definitely this is the end game
the bible says so and whether people
like it or not
there's so much argument about the mark
of the beast
only the beast can define what its mark
is
and it's done that on many occasions
it is the mark of our ecclesiastical
power
that we change the day because it
confirms our authority over
and above the bible that is an affront
to god how do you oppose that you can't
yes you can martin you can keep saturday
oh yeah
yes you're opposing it you are saying no
no no hang on a second
that is sheer arrogance what you are
saying your authority supersedes the
bible
i will show you that i believe that the
bible supersedes your authority
and i will keep saturday because god
said so
100 you agree yes okay
so what we saw in the vatican statement
is basically confirmed here by the
public statement of the european sunday
alliance
which again gave this joint statement of
the european sunday alliance
on the occasion of the annual european
day for a work-free sunday on march 3
2021 1700 years sunday protection
the value of synchronized free time in
time of
increasing digitalization
i find it interesting that free time has
to do with
digitalization computer
and all of these things are involved
over here so again they talk about the
emperor bottom line is is
this becoming a major talking point
definitely is the power
that the bible identifies
that power in rome behind
a push for this legislation yes
it wasn't because it confirms its
authority
right definitely and when nations
comply aren't they
lifting up the authority of this power
over and above the bible
yes so whose authority are they there by
attacking
god's authority so this is what we're
trying to say
it's not a question of a day it's a
question of whose authority
do you regard as paramount
and the fact that it is coupled to a day
is actually
brilliant imagine martin if it were
coupled to a pilgrimage to a certain
place and you undercover it locked down
and you cannot go there
you cannot go there many religious
systems have
compulsory pilgrimages to show that you
are in line with their authority right
correct so could god have
made it a place that you have to visit
to show that you acknowledge his
authority
or maybe yes but that would cut out most
of humanity exactly that won't
work but a day it's going to come to you
whether you like it or not
even if you're sitting in some jungle
exactly and
how easy is it actually now for them to
use
all these ways of
implementing restrictions and all of
this
to say we have to keep this one day
one day the way they've been using the
restrictions
and the laws that they've written in
around the pandemic
just shows you that they're geared to
start implementing this when they've
decided on it it's the writing is on the
wall
on march 3 the annual european day for a
work-free sunday the european sunday
alliance calls on political leaders in
europe
to put synchronized free time as a
priority on the social policy agenda
and help make a tangible visible and
cherished improvement in the lives of
citizens across
europe now there's a word that stands
out there martin
that's the word synchronized free time
which actually means that everybody must
keep
exactly the same free time
so you cannot stagger it no you cannot
say okay you can have a day off on a
wednesday
and you can you can have a day off on a
friday the sabbath keepers can keep
their sabbath on a saturday on a
saturday night
no free time is going to be synchronized
universally that means one day
take it or leave it
so there is a definite
movement in the world
in a direction which is
prophesied in this book
and it hinges on the authority
of god the world has removed
the authority of god systematically
he's been taken out of the political
arena for the sake of fraternity
the name of jesus has been removed in
many many places
in public meetings you're not allowed to
use that because it goes against
fraternity it's been a
a progressive change laws of
morality have changed they've become
freer and now there is this massive
movement
towards synchronized
free time and sunday
is at the hub and it is the logical day
it's already entrenched in so many
countries
either in tradition or in blue laws or
in this
or in that and we see a push
and there is a little group of people
that is warning
against what is happening in the world
and saying
excuse me we want to show you that this
has been prophesied in the bible
and that this is a sign of the end
what would be a counter strategy for
that let's have a look
here's the express end of the world
prophecy
bible warns of terrible times in the
end days now martin they're not for this
they are against this right this is
in the same light as the cnn report
on the trump supporters exactly so it's
ridiculing people
that see bible prophecy end times
fulfilling before their eyes
end of the world prophecies about the
end days and the second coming of christ
are shaping up around the world at least
according to outrageous claims
made by a christian's conspiracy theory
blog niche groups of conspiracy
theorists believe
these signs are already unfolding and
there's not much time left on the clock
before the final judgment
do you fall into that category
yes yes and although there is no
credible evidence scientific or
religious
to back these claims the blog authors
are convinced
recent socio-political turmoil is
evidence of biblical prophecy coming to
fruition
now martin there's prophecy in this
prophecy
and many of the prophets out there we
must still do one
on all of these prophets right they're
saying many many things
and many don't realize that what they've
actually incorporated in their thinking
is something that has been predigested
in the stable of rome so the whole
theory of futurism
the whole theory of a literal israel
which will again be in charge of the
world
under this thousand-year period when the
church will have been
raptured that's not biblical that's not
biblical at all
the bible clearly tells us that in the
tribulation everybody will be here
the plagues will be falling and the type
that you had in egypt
where the children of israel were
present while the
plagues fell is the type for the
antitype
you're not going to violate the type and
change the conditions and the antitype
so none of these things are biblical so
there's so much confusion
out there there's such an intermingling
of ideas
but number one anybody
who says that bible signs are fulfilling
is a conspiracy theory that's what
they're saying now that's what they're
saying
so who's all a conspiracy theorist if
you believe
in 1844 and the second coming of christ
then the judgment
like the millerites believed then you're
a conspiracy theorist
if you believe like the q anons believe
you're a conspiracy theorist you believe
in the six day literal creation
then you are a conspiracy theorist now
if you believe in the end times
yeah now if you well it comes to if you
actually believe
what the bible the bible says if you use
that book
you're a conspiracy theorist so i'm
afraid that level is going to stick
excellent so perhaps we should be proud
of that label
yes end of the world
prophecy these those
signs include the rise of iran turkey
china now they're giving all of these
signs the great
reset agenda 21 they're throwing in
everything in there
the antichrist will falsely declare
himself the true messiah in an act
described by
experts as the greatest deceit in
history
there's truth mingled with area because
the bible also
says that even even the elite will be
deceived will be deceived
and satan will masquerade as an angel of
light he will come
but before that there will be a false
messiah so
that it's such a intermingling of truth
and error that
i can understand why people get confused
out there and there are so many prophets
out there shouting that this will happen
and that will happen and none of it
happens
correct why because they are
mixing the truth in this word
with the conjectures and philosophies
that have been introduced into the
christian world
by the beast itself and futurism
pre-terrorism
all of that stuff and that's why we'll
do an episode
on these prophets and what they are i
think we should
so they're they're talking here about
the authors of uh
the signposts of the times claim there's
another sign of prophecy that is
presently unfolding
and that is the breakdown of morality
individualism and the love of
materialism these are
general things which we've also
discussed which are signs
truly they are well um from what we've
seen in the world now it's not
it doesn't take a rocket science just
to realize that this is happening
correct
and then they quote ii timothy chapter 3
1-5
about the state of the world that the
love of many will grow
cold they will be unforgiving and many
bible experts however reject all
attempts to try and predict the date
for the return of jesus christ and then
one of the pastors
of pepperoni christian fellowship says
such a stance is unethical to the
promise that
is the second coming of christ the bible
expert
added as claim of the claim of the
imminent return of jesus has proven
wrong over the last two thousand years
jesus's words have
proven true
but we are still admonished in the word
of god to
watch yes and to be watchmen
and to discern the times and there will
be a final decree that will go
out the mark of the beast
and that that is the final sign
have we seen that have we had the proof
on the screen yes i believe so
here's another interesting one from
january 25
joe biden bible prophecy god
will use the u.s president to usher in
the
tribulation now we don't have to read
the whole thing
of course this is incorporating futurism
from the jesuit stable into christianity
the great tribulation
god's people will be raptured before
that and many see
that joe biden is the one who's going to
usher it in
and they're putting it under the
category of conspiracy theories
none of this is going to happen now i'm
not saying
and i think you're not saying that it
will definitely happen unto joe biden
yeah but it could it could
it could if these signs continue
the way they are it certainly could yes
so martin when you study this book
and you study prophecy there is a
true fulfillment of prophecy
which you have to glean from the pages
of the bible
and then there is this jumbled mixture
to change the clear picture into a
picture of
mud and this is why
the critics can take hold of these
things
and ridicule it and that is why they can
discredit
the people that are saying something
about a end time event it's because of
this mingling of truth and error
and it makes a confusion confusion now
what does the word babylon stand for
confusion
confusion that's what we have
so when we talk about these issues we
must be very
clear as to why we believe
that we are living in the last days
we must look at the very distinct signs
which the bible is giving us
which will take place yes there will be
lovers of money
the people will be disobedient children
will be disobedient to their parents
but you can take that out of virtually
any generation in the past as well the
60s were
replete with that kind of behavior you
had the drug scene you had
the fall of morality those are all signs
but the final final crux of the matter
is to make null and void
the authority of god
and whether we like it or not
that authority is
linked to the sabbath
that is where god has placed the seal
of his authority and that is why the
antichrist has placed the seal of
his authority on the day that he has
changed
that is the final choice who
is the authority in your life
let's pray heavenly father
we are seeing the fulfillment of
prophecy before
our eyes and i pray
that god's people will wake up and see
where this
is heading help us to find
our way through the maze
through the disinformation through the
ridicule
so that we can make our stand on the
clear
thus says the lord this is my prayer
in jesus name amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe to our channel
click here to get notifications click on
the bell
to watch the next video click here
thank you and we'll see you again